There was a time when kids could enjoy an
animated classic without their parents worrying
about what they were really learning.
Or so we thought.
It isn't just modern kids films that conceal
adult issues, but some of the most beloved
movies of the past send some truly weird messages
that older fans may have never even realized.
The Jungle Book
When the hero of your story is a boy raised
by a completely different species, and was
written by a man living through England's
colonization of India, it's obvious that ideas
and philosophies will overlap.
Basically, Kipling's Jungle Book can be seen
as a massive metaphor for Britain's view of
India, with Mowgli in Britain's role, and
the animals as Indians.
But the bigger message is a bit less disturbing,
since the jungle boy eventually learns that
human villagers are just as strange to animals
as the other way around - it's just a matter
of perspective.
Still, the overall message of people sticking
with their own kind is always going to be
a tricky one to explain to kids.
The Lion King There was no better King than
Mufasa, and his parents obviously knew it
the moment he was born, naming him after an
actual African King.
But you have to wonder: what was his brother
Scar's name BEFORE he got the Scar?
Disney's Lion King novels revealed his name
was originally "Taka," but he took the name
Scar so he'd never forget how anger and jealousy
almost cost him an eye.
Since that actually makes him seem decent,
it's probably his parents who are to blame
for him turning out evil: in Swahili, "Taka"
means dirt, or trash.
Harsh.
The Secret of NIMH
This cult classic may not have come from Disney,
but its tale of intelligent mice and rats
earned it critical acclaim - from adults.
But kids might have missed the actual disturbing
story at work, thanks to the magic elements
added to the book it's based on.
The flashback to the rats and other animals
being tested is scary to young viewers, but
older ones able to grasp that NIMH is really
the National Institute of Mental Health may
realize that the movie is one big warning
about what medical research can create if
the ones in charge go too far.
All Dogs Go To Heaven
You can't even blame a bad dog for being that
way, since, as this hugely successful movie
taught us, all dogs go to heaven.
Or, at least kids are led to believe that.
When the star dog gives up heaven to head
back to Earth, he's warned that if he dies
again, he won't return - but he's never told
what will happen instead.
But as he starts making dishonest, selfish
choices, a nightmare sequence confirms what
every older viewer fears: where there's a
doggie heaven, there's a doggie hell.
Kids might see it as just a bad dream, but
the lava, the demonic doggie devil, and even
the hellhounds tearing at Charlie's hair are
pretty grim for a movie with such a sweet
message.
The Good Dinosaur
It's the classic story of a boy and his dog
- except the boy is the dog this time around,
with a dinosaur named Arlo as the star.
Pixar is know for jokes aimed squarely at
parents, but The Good Dinosaur goes further
than usual when the heroes start to bond over
what else?
An intense drug trip.
Thanks to some fermenting fruit, the two of
them get hallucinating instantly, leaving
younger audiences wondering how bad fruit
can swap the characters heads, and send them
flying through the air.
While older viewers realize what story the
filmmakers are really telling.
Alice in Wonderland
Every kid learns about Alice's journey down
the rabbit hole sooner or later, and when
every one of them sees it again as an adult,
it's hard to believe that it's basically all
just one big drug trip.
Well, maybe not according to Disney, but watching
as Alice eats magical mushrooms that make
her feel giant, tiny, or floating through
the air all speak for themselves.
Why parents would tease their kids with the
amazing adventures eating mushrooms can take
them on is a mystery.
That's not even mentioning the slow, drowsy
caterpillar who can't stop smoking... something.
Use your imagination.
The Little Mermaid
She wasn't the first Disney princess to ignore
her parents advice, but Ariel the mermaid
went farther than most, basically making a
deal with the devil, swapping her tail for
legs after falling in love with a man.
But the deal has a catch: if he doesn't fall
in love with her fast enough, she loses everything.
It's a chance to tell a serious cautionary
tale, or at least it would be, if the movie
didn't end with the evil Witch murdered, and
Ariel living happily ever after.
Basically, teaching kids that selling your
soul is a bad idea...
If you don't do the smart thing, and kill
the one you sold it to.
Wreck-it Ralph
Being the bad guy isn't anyone's first choice,
so when Ralph decides he wants to be a Hero
instead, he makes his dream come true.
Well, not quite.
You see, in the video game universe, it doesn't
really matter if you want to be a Hero or
villain...
Things only work if everyone plays their role.
It's a surprisingly depressing message to
send to kids, revealing that bad guys don't
necessarily have to be BAD guys.
They can be good at heart...
But yeah.
They're still bad.
Snow White
There are a few Disney morals that never change:
love beats hate, good beats evil, and nothing
is as important as being beautiful.
That's the message made clear by Snow White,
who almost gets killed for breaking and entering,
until the dwarves see her face.
It's even her beauty that sends the evil Queen
after her, in fact it's the only reason.
Get the message kids, being beautiful saves
lives, but can also get you killed.
And after she's eaten the poisoned apple,
what is it that breaks the Curse?
She's so beautiful, Prince charming can't
help but kiss her when he lays eyes on her
lifeless body.
Creepy.
Zootopia
It isn't hard to see how many serious messages
are sent with this Disney hit, since it all
begins when a strange new drug - cooked in
a secret lab by a sheep version of Breaking
Bad's - starts turning everyday animals into
out of control maniacs.
Add the fact that it's only minorities turning
feral, with the police suggesting they're
biologically prone to violence, and whether
intentional or not, Zootopia couldn't be more
relevant to the issues of racism in today's
world.
Those are the children's movies we found sending
some seriously complicated or downright weird
messages to their audience, but which ones
have we missed?
Let us know in the comments and subscribe
for more videos like this one.